je
mouvement de tchi kong son temple d'où
l'enchaînement harmonieux quasi poétique
cette gymnastique traditionnelle
chinoise associe gestuelle lente et
postures physiques respiration et
travail du souffle concentration et
conscience corporelle elle requiert des
principes de base une enracinant la
fluidité
l'unité du corps le vide le plein le
ying et le yang ces élèves en tenue
décontractée maîtrise les enchaînements
et semble ainsi hors du temps et juste
après le court je me sens en pleine
forme j'ai envie d'entreprendre plein de
choses j'ai beaucoup récupéré je me sens
présent d'accord mecs qui m'ont tout
aussi quand j'en ai besoin je le
pratique à la maison ou d'un nature et
en fait ça devient une hygiène de vie en
fait est un bonheur les visages comme
les corps apparaisse détendu paisible
cette discipline ancestrale plaît même
pour ses bienfaits sur certains mots
beaucoup de rigidité beaucoup de
problèmes
de liaison entre les différentes parties
du corps beaucoup de problèmes
rhumatismaux on a la surprise de voir
des personnes arrivées finalement très
handicapée et en quelques séances on les
voit réussir des exercices dont on se
demande s'ils sont vraiment les mêmes
personnes qu'on avait vu quelques
semaines auparavant les journées
nationales du ti kong se déroule du 3 au
9 juin l'occasion de s'essayer à cette
discipline lors d'ateliers découverte
gratuit